en este vídeo vamos a ver las
diferencias entre la núcleo feel y that
y la base cidad empecemos con la núcleo
feel y that núcleo feel y that se
refiere a la velocidad en la que un
núcleo filo ataca a un electro filo y
existen dos factores que pueden tomar en
cuenta cuando pensamos en la fuerza
núcleo física la primera es la carga
vamos a comparar dos moléculas y veamos
cuál de las dos es mejor como núcleo
filo por aquí el año net óxido y por acá
una molécula de etanol analicemos cuál
de las dos moléculas es mejor como
núcleo filo en el lado derecho
tenemos un oxígeno con una carga parcial
negativa es más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno entonces el hidrógeno tiene
una carga parcial positiva si un electro
filo entra en la reacción dibujaré un
electro filo general por aquí está
cargado positivamente la pregunta es
cuál de estas moléculas se sentirá más
atraída al electro filo
la molécula con una carga formal
negativa o la que tiene una carga
parcial negativa bueno la carga formal
negativa se sentirá más atraída al
electro filo entonces en la unión stock
sido atacar
al electro filo más rápido que el etanol
eso significa que este es el núcleo filo
fuerte lo escribiré núcleo filo fuerte
entonces el etanol es un núcleo filo
débil núcleo filo
débil así que todo se trata de la
velocidad de ataque el otro factor que
debemos tomar en cuenta es la polarizada
lidad de la molécula polaris habilidad
dibujaré otro par de moléculas
la polarizada es la habilidad de algo
para ser polarizado usualmente debido a
influencias externas veamos un ejemplo
de ello otra vez he dibujado la molécula
de etanol como ejemplo y por aquí está
un azufre sustituyendo al oxígeno el
azufre y pertenece al mismo grupo de la
tabla periódica al que pertenece el
oxígeno por lo que reacciona de manera
similar pero cuando pongo los pares de
electrones libres necesito conocer el
tamaño del átomo sabemos que el azufre
es un átomo más grande que el oxígeno
eso nos dice la tabla periódica entonces
lo exagerar un poco digamos que los
electrones en el oxígeno se encuentran
muy cerca del núcleo mientras que para
el azufre como es un átomo grande sus
electrones están más separados del
núcleo lo estoy exagerando un poco pero
ahí están recuerden que el núcleo está
cargado positivamente y los electrones
están cargados negativamente si estos
electrones están más lejos del núcleo
entonces el núcleo tendrá menos
influencia sobre ellos esto es parte de
la física entre mayor distancia exista
entre cargas opuestas menor será la
atracción entre ellas así que estos
electrones en el azufre no están muy
unidos al núcleo y si un electro filo
aparece dibujaré un electro fy lo
general está cargado positivamente estos
electrones que están cargados
negativamente se sentirán atraídos por
el electro filo esto polarizará aún más
al átomo de azufre estos electrones
estarán más disponibles para atacar al
electro filo mientras que de este lado
no podremos tener una gran diferencia de
polaridad
porque estos electrones no pueden
alejarse mucho del núcleo entonces si de
este lado aunque un poco exagerado estos
electrones están cargados negativamente
el azufre está cargado positivamente hay
polaridad y tendremos mayor polaridad
conforme los electrones se alejen más
del átomo permitiéndoles atacar al
electro filo lo mismo ocurre con los
halógenos por ejemplo el a nyon yoduro
es una unión muy grande y estos
electrones están muy lejos del núcleo
el yoduro es muy polarizado lo que lo
convierte en un núcleo filo fuerte
entonces tanto el tío esta molécula como
el yoduro son núcleos filos fuertes y el
etanol es otra vez un núcleo filo débil
ahora hablemos de la base cidad cuando
analizamos la base cidad de algo ese
algo se suele clasificar como una base
fuerte o una base débil y una forma de
saberlo es revisando el pp
de los ácidos conjugados
hagamos un ejemplo rápido digamos que
queremos saber si el año un cloruro es
una base fuerte o débil el cl - será una
base fuerte o débil bueno una manera de
saberlo es con el ácido conjugado de
este año en cloruro es decir simplemente
añadimos un protón y nos queda el h cl
ya que tenemos esto podemos buscar los
valores de pk
en el caso del ácido clorhídrico su pk
es de aproximadamente menos 7 y sabemos
que a bajos pk
el ácido es más fuerte y claro el ácido
clorhídrico es un ácido fuerte pero así
como el ácido es fuerte la base
conjugada es débil por lo que el año en
cloruro es una base débil
hagamos una reacción ácido base para
probar esto si hacemos reaccionar
hcl con agua
esta es una reacción ácido base simple
de química general
sabemos que el ácido clorhídrico actuará
como un ácido y el agua actuará como una
base el agua tomará este protón y estos
electrones se quedarán con el cloro así
se forma el ión hidronew h 3 o más
y también se forma el año en cloruro
muy bien ahora quiero preguntarles si
aquí tenemos a la neón cloruro podría
tomar este protón para formar el hc l no
eso no sucede el cloruro no es una base
fuerte por lo que sólo se da la reacción
hacia la derecha
la reacción reversible no sucede entre
más fuerte sea el ácido más débil es la
base conjugada así que podemos
clasificar a la unión cloruro como una
base débil ahora analicemos al & óxido
quiero saber si el año net óxido es una
base fuerte o una base débil y para eso
haremos lo mismo vamos a dibujar su
ácido conjugado solo le añadimos un
protón y nos queda el etanol
cuál es el teca del etanol bueno es de
aproximadamente 16 a comparación del
valor del pk del ácido clorhídrico que
es de menos 7
es muy ácido un valor bajo de pk indica
que es muy ácido mientras que un valor
alto de pecado indica que es poco ácido
así que un pecado de 16 es mucho menos
ácido que un pecado de menos 7 eso
significa que el etanol como ácido es
muy débil a comparación del hcl entonces
si tenemos un ácido débil significa que
tenemos una base fuerte y eso coincide
con todos los anones alcor óxido todos
son bases fuertes ya analizamos la
núcleo feel y that y la base cidad
hagamos un pequeño resumen de lo que
hemos aprendido en términos de fuerza
núcleo física fuerza básica y cuáles son
veamos primero aquellos que solamente
actúan como núcleo filos en un mecanismo
es decir que no son buenos como base son
bases débiles pero núcleo filos fuertes
los halógenos entran en esta categoría
hablamos por ejemplo de lyon cloruro que
es una base débil y un núcleo filo
fuerte tiene todos estos pares de
electrones libres y una carga formal
negativa actúa como núcleo filo fuerte
al igual que todos los halógenos como el
bromuro el yoduro dijimos que el yoduro
es un núcleo filo fuerte también como
núcleo filos fuertes hablamos de los
troles este tío es un núcleo filo fuerte
y al igual que la unión hidróxido es el
año nido sulfuro los troles son bases
débiles porque los ácidos conjugados son
más fuertes
estos son los más importantes que
solamente actúan como núcleo filos ahora
que puede funcionar solamente como una
base
bueno el mejor ejemplo de esto es el año
ni duro está cargado negativamente si
reaccionará con otro protón se formaría
hidrógeno gaseoso así que actuara como
una base no actuará como un núcleo filo
porque es un ión muy pequeño lo que
significa que sus electrones se
encuentran muy cerca del núcleo entonces
no se polariza fácilmente baja habilidad
para ser polarizado
por eso no puede funcionar muy bien como
un núcleo filo pero sí como una base por
ejemplo el hidro de sodio es una base
muy fuerte con la que podemos tener una
reacción de dos en los siguientes vídeos
hablaremos con más detalle sobre las
reacciones de eliminación contra las de
sustitución pero en este vídeo es muy
importante que entiendan cómo clasificar
las cosas en núcleo filos y envases así
le será más fácil identificar otras
cosas ya vimos algunos ejemplos de
núcleo filos fuertes y de bases fuertes
otro ejemplo que vimos fue el año net
óxido vimos que este año puede actuar
como un núcleo filo fuerte o una base
fuerte
entonces los sal cox y dos entran en
esta categoría un al coc sido general se
escribe como r o menos y los hidróxidos
también están aquí es la misma idea
pueden funcionar como núcleo filo fuerte
o base fuerte y ahora para la categoría
de núcleo filo débil base débil
si protón amos a las moléculas que
tenemos a la derecha por ejemplo si
protón amos a la unión hidróxido
formamos h2o el agua tiene pares de
electrones libres en el oxígeno que
pueden funcionar como núcleo filo o como
base pero no es muy bueno para ello por
eso el agua es un núcleo filo débil y
una base débil ahora sí protón amos a la
unión al cocido se forma un alcohol que
tampoco es un núcleo filo fuerte puede
funcionar como núcleo filo porque tiene
pares de electrones libres pero no es
fuerte y puede actuar como base pero
tampoco es una base fuerte estos son dos
ejemplos de núcleo filos débiles y bases
débiles
primero clasifica en algo como núcleo
filo fuerte o débil y luego como una
base fuerte o débil ahora si ya están
listos para comparar reacciones de
eliminación contra las de sustitución